[Music]  season the chicken breasts back to hot  olive oil skin-side down lay away from  you to stop it all splashing  sliced chicory this versatile vegetable  can be read all white has a lovely  bitter taste and his great cooked or raw  crush a clove of garlic and add their  sprigs of thyme  when the chicken skin is crisp turnover  along with the chicory  for the sauce at masala a sweet  fortified wine from Sicily  then 150 mil of chicken stock to make  the sauce wander too rich in glossy add  butter and simmer for 10 minutes  plate up and spoon over the source  cooked and under 20 minutes chicken and  chicory in masala sauce scallops have  firm white sweet flesh and cook in  minutes after a minute on a low heat add  coriander basil and lemon